[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and thirteen
reasons why has just dropped its third
season on Netflix the controversial show
has had a lot of questions surrounding
it since the beginning
and while season three answers some it
still leaves a lot unanswered throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the finale and giving my thoughts on the
Bryce Walker Killer reveal there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch it yet and don't
want to have anything ruined then I
highly suggest you turn off now if
you're still here I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into my breakdown of 13
reasons why season 3 the final episode
of 13 reasons why ends with Annie
disclosing during an interview with
sheriff's tandel that implicates Monty
as the killer of Bryce Walker the
character whose death pretty much became
the main talking point of season 3 the
highly hated teen died disgraced and
with very few friends which meant that
since his death everyone has been a
suspect whilst it looks like it will be
Monty who takes the fall we actually
discovered that the killer was in fact
Alex it's highly implicated that this
lie will unravel in season 4 as the
characters in the show begin to realize
that things don't really add up it's a
really shocking twist that showcases
that 13 reasons why still has a lot of
twists and turns going forward and
there's actually very little things in
the season that are straight forward
towards the latter part of season 3 we
begin to unravel why Bryce ended up
where he did and we learn that the
character approached Jessica and told
her that he needed to give her something
special this of course set off alarm
bells and he was obviously quite anxious
about going to see him at the docks
which is where the two agreed to meet
from here we see Zack in episode 12
confronting Bryce at the meeting point
which sent his mainly around Chloe's
pregnancy Zack beats him very badly and
we see firsthand that Bryce is still the
same monster underneath that has
apparently been put to bed this is
cemented by the fact that he blames Zack
face breakup with Chloe which pretty
much confirms that he doesn't really
feel any guilt over the things
put her through and is completely
removed psychologically from the crimes
that he committed Brice is still a bad
guy and he refuses to accept any
responsibility that he was the one who
did any wrongdoings and this shows that
he hasn't changed in the slightest he
even asks Zach if he and Chloe had sex
which showcases that he doesn't really
see her as a person and only views her
as an object in response
zach breaks his leg and leaves him which
is when Jessica and Alex arrived to find
the character who he learned was wanting
to give Jessica a confession tape in an
attempt to be better this epiphany is
quickly quashed though when Bryce states
he's gone to runes axe live no matter
what it costs which makes Alex realize
that he's still the same old person deep
down and he pushes him into the river to
drown in what I'm not gonna lie
was a pretty satisfying moment don't cap
me and he places the blame squarely on
Monty but as we see in the season finale
this lie will definitely unravel and
cause a lot more bad than good going
forward Winston has discovered that it
wasn't Monty at least who killed Bryce
so this leaves a lot of possibilities
for the future
Winston of course knew what Monty was
going through and spent a lot of time
with him so will no doubt probably want
is truth to come out and be public
knowledge going forward this has a lot
of repercussions to it with a
potentially causing a huge upset down
the line that could massively impact the
characters lives including Annie who is
pretty much lied to the authorities
there's also the issue of the huge
cover-up for Alex which will incriminate
many other people including his father
who participated in destroying evidence
in order to save his son I think that 13
reasons why season four will definitely
open a huge can of worms for all the
characters and that's without even
discussing the discovery of the guns
which will definitely cause huge issues
going forward there's just so many
aspects that will pretty much ruin all
of the characters lives and I think that
season 4 has the potential to be an even
bigger dramatic piece than its
predecessors obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on 13 reasons why and what
you hope to see down the line if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of this weekend's are the big release
already or not which will be linked at
the end I cover everything you need to
know about the movies so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
you wanna come talk to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books and you
can follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this I also just want to let you know
that we're giving away a free copy of
John wick 3 on blu-ray and all you have
to do to be in with a chance of winning
is to like this video and leave your
thoughts on 13 reasons why in the
comments section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blu-ray will
be shipped out from then - if I get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]